Hãy tình hình thân tay linh tiếp gây tị thạch trên dịch dọng, Trung ước mặt trận tổ quốc Việt Nam đã nỗ lực vấn mộ nguồn kíu trợ một cách công bằng minh bài bảo đam nước không dồn trộ chủ.
Mỗi khoản hỗ trợ được cân cứ ước theo thủ kê tị thạch cụ thể từ điều phương, yêu tiền hộng ngheu, vùng trí hoàn hưởng năng.
Ông cao sân thảo, trưởng bán công tác sả hội Trung ước mặt trận tổ quốc Việt Nam cho biết, mỗi điều phương trự tị thạch mất lộ khác nhau,
nếu nhiều bảo chào gây năng hành hình khục trọng hài tư, tàn phá các tình miền bác tập trục một thời điểm,
thì năm nay bảo trường bảo lên tiếp thử dàn dài từ miền Trung xa miền bác đều hữu chiều.
Nếu địa bàn trước đây cho bị ảnh hưởng năng, thì nãy chự thiền tài vừa sau vừa giống,
nếu thành phố tháng quên của ốc, cao bằng bác sản của ốc, nguồn tiền được phân bộ cân cụ trên thống kê thị thạch từ các địa phương.
Mặt trận tổ quốc Việt Nam cũng như các cấp chính quyền, những thức rất só yêu cầu về sự công bằng khách quan trọng kíu trở,
nên sẵn sách hỗ trợ sẽ được nếu ít cộ khai ở từng thôn sống, thay vị trì đến cấp 3 như trước đây.
Trong đó, hộ nghèo sẽ được 3 sát trước để bảo đàn khu bỏ sốt.